GOOD POSITION.
GOOD BODY.!
FIVE.
TAKES UP A LOT OF SPACE.
>> Willy: MENTIONED HIM AND HIS
SIZE AT 6'5".
HE HAS GOT
THAT WHEN HE COMES DOWN.
THAT IS GOING TO OPEN UP  SPACE
BALANCE BACK.
THE NET.
, COUSINS.
FORECHECK AWAY.
2 ON
JUST ABSOLUTELY RIPS IT.
BACKHAND FOR DUCHENE STOPPED.
REBOUND AND A
I JUST LOVE THAT.HE DOORSTEP, T
THE POWER PLAY GOAL.
THAT DID NOT
WAY.
I THINK HE TALKS IT IN.
GRANLUND KEEPS THE ATTACK
MOVING.
CUCUIS TIED.
THERE AND DO
SO CALMLY GUIDES IT IN.
GREAT PLAY THERE .GUDBRANSON WO
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
>> ChrLOOK, VERY IMPRESSIVE.
A BIG MAN.
A LOT OF SAVES
THE WARRENSBURG LOOKING FOR  BR
>> Chris: UNBELIEVABTO
THE PARK.
SHILLINGTON ON THE SEAT.
THIS ONE RIGHT
HE TAKES CONTROL AND
TRYING TO GET HIM MATT TO.
>> Chris:
>> Willy: NOT EVEN CLOSE.
HE SCORES.